what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we got ourselves a trailer
for werewolf by night right now just
want to give a heads up our secret
invasion trailer blocked everyone's
getting blocked right now i'm sure
disney will eventually be like maybe we
shouldn't be blocking this and there's
nothing really dude what are you going
to watch a reaction with no audio no
visuals you can't do that but anyway
guys andrew how are you i'm doing well
john never better now i'm not that
familiar with werewolf by night but
andrew's pretty well versed in it right
now how are you
good
you mean first and foremost
i know i know about where we'll find out
yes jack russell what's this these are
mr technical over here all right let's
get to it leave a like
[Music]
this halloween
you can't escape
oh my god
werewolf by night
oh my god that's awesome it is every
hunter for themselves there is good luck
i'll be
rotting for you
one of you is my monster
masquerading as one of our own
i can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
oh
i love it
oh my god
please don't do this
is coming for you
is that oh is it a man thing
[Music]
are they really doing this
this feels like something you'd want
marvel to do but would never do
straight out of the 30s and 40s
oh i'm in love that was incredible i
finally know what love is that was
absolutely incredible
thanks marvel that was visually
stimulating oh my goodness gracious oh
like creature feature classic universal
monster horror with that grind house b
touch to it it felt actually like a
little horrific at times with cheesy and
k oh my god i was not expecting that is
the most horror marvel's ever felt and
it's so fun and michael you got who's
michael jacino yeah michael giachino
directed this right yeah oh my god
i
love this
yeah even if it was just like some
fan-made trailer like if they were to do
werewolf by night here's what it would
be i feel like man i love that trailer
this is so so refreshing so refreshing
andrew what's where we'll find out uh so
werewolf by night is uh we see jacob
russoff but he is now known as jack
russell and basically he's a character
of circumstance there's a family uh
history or basically it's a family curse
that happened from this great great
great great grandfather he was bitten by
a werewolf and now uh his gra i believe
it was his grandfather was uh
read uh from the dark hold and unleashed
their family curse of uh
the werewolf and now that's why uh jacob
or jack russell rather has it and yeah
no it's uh gonna be interesting i'm
hoping to that i believe it's what is it
gail garcia um what's the actual bernal
yes i loved him so much in coco he
really embodied uh that character hector
and just gave him so much humanity so
i'm really curious to see him as jack
russell i know we obviously didn't get
to see any of him in this trailer it was
a teaser but
i'm really looking forward to seeing him
as jack russell because again jack
russell is such a character of such a
victim of circumstance so i think that
you know gael can really bring that
because he brought that to me at least
from hector just the humanity he brought
to that so really looking forward to
that i'm hoping that this show if it's
really popular can we we can get some
maybe uh
at some point we can see like maybe a
formation of the legion of monsters
which is a group of uh four characters
that we get we get morbius we get ghost
writers
yeah one man thing i think there is a
flat like you see that like icky looking
snoot and one of those flashes i'm
pretty sure that he pops up in here
somewhere oh nice yeah but it's gonna
it's interesting they got michael
jacquino i mean i love his his uh his
scores that he does in all his films
he's phenomenal i love the batman coco
up all those films and it's really
interesting to see him and gael uh
come back together because obviously
they have a rapport from what they did
in coco obviously you know with all the
music that they did together so i'm
really curious to see how they work
together from a director to actor point
of view now so ah all right
john yeah this is exactly 110 percent up
my alley and i think ayo garcia bernal
has a really perfect look for the era
and the type of film style they're going
for you know he has
i don't know just something that feels
right at home in a sort of gothic but
also b grind house uh you know yeah
lycanthropy story and i love that you
have yeah it's just these mixing tones
it almost feels like a house on haunted
hills scenario you've got all these like
hunters gathered together and i love
that idea of the
you know the hunted hiding among the
hunters trying to pass himself off as
one of them and uh and it's great that
you should mention morbius in the sony
universe because this is a literal
game of werewolf thing going on on
screen which i think is really funny and
charming and now i just want to see how
they you know carry this tone over the
whole special because
you know i mean
as as a trailer i feel like you can
sometimes lean more heavily into like
hey hey we're getting you know sort of
very very stylized in this particular
time and setting and it makes me wonder
what the breathing room of this is is
gonna feel like watching grindhouse or
is it gonna step back a little bit with
the style when we actually get to see
the special itself but just the the
portents of this are really engrossing
and engaging and if there are like it
seems like yeah they're you know you'll
have the world by night uh sort of you
know being hunted situation already but
then you have these other characters
like a man thing or whoever else that
might show up so yeah i'm wondering what
kind of monstrous threats this will
introduce to the mcu i mean this phase
we've gotten kind of used to things not
directly having major connectivity but
uh especially with blade and other
things coming up i feel like this can
easily help to expand the hellish and
the horrific side of the mcu in a way
that yeah is also just like perfect fun
for halloween time and yeah this easily
shot up i was already anticipating it
just based on who the character is alone
but seeing this and seeing them be
really embracing of
that style and aesthetic is just so much
fun and i love that the mcu that they're
trying to do something a little bit
different you know with the supernatural
they're really you know leaning towards
you know dark gritty and scary i mean
yeah we got a little bit of taste of
that multiverse of madness with scarlet
witch and we've gotten little bits of uh
in other mcu films but really like
focusing on a series that delves deep
into something that they really haven't
explored in the uh other things with the
mcu i'm really looking forward to that i
mean this looked like nothing we've seen
in the mcu from tone from a tone
perspective so yeah i thought it was
perfect
that was absolutely perfect
it actually i'm surprised that when you
hear michael giaccino honestly my my
first thought was
it's probably going to be like as by the
numbers as you'd expect so when i saw
this commitment to the flare and the
style i was very much impressed by it
and it looks like it could even get like
a little violent
and uh because it's black and white they
might feel like they can get away with a
little more yeah you know it better be
violent i mean this character is a
savage so i hope so yeah yeah i liked it
a lot i was i'm very much dazzled by
that i cannot wait to watch that that
was awesome
um i hope it's not annoying though uh
because that is the thing you would
bring it up like it could be it's
probably just a little too indulgent
with its style that the scenes can get
annoying but because that's a problem
with sometimes when you try to ape a
certain type of time period but i don't
know i feel like they might reel him
back on certain moments being noticed it
still doesn't feel like a good story
we're telling you yeah it's a connected
[ __ ] so yeah make it a good good thing
um but yeah guys uh thank you for being
here uh hopefully you get that secret
invasion video blocked unblocked i mean
i am looking at four uploads right now
over there that are all blocked can't
get it up
but uh we'll see
[Music]